como dijimos en el vídeo anterior vimos
series geométricas o bueno funciones
vistas como series geométricas y luego
suponiendo que la proporción común que
era nuestra nuestra variable x tiene un
valor absoluto menor que 1 entonces
tenemos lo que lo que vale dicha suma
que vimos ya hace algunos vídeos con
esta fórmula ahora vamos en sentido
contrario vamos a tomar una función
digamos digamos ésta hdx hdx igual a 1
entre 3 más x cuadrada y vamos a ir al
revés porque ahora vamos a ponerla en
vamos a tratar de ponerla de esta forma
para poder representarla como una serie
geométrica muy bien así que te invito a
que hagas una pausa y que pienses cómo
resolver este problema
ok entonces vamos a tratar de hacerlo
primero lo que tenemos que ver es que
aquí hay un 1 y aquí tenemos un 3
así que una forma de obtener este 1 es
factor izando este 3 así que lo podemos
poner como 1 entre 3 que multiplica a 1
más
x cuadradas sobre 3 simplemente factor
izamos ese 3
si uno hace este producto puede ver que
se obtiene esto muy bien así que este 3
lo podemos pasar en él denomina el
perdón del denominador el numerador de
la siguiente forma lo podemos poner como
un tercio entre
y ahora ponemos uno y no tenemos que
necesitamos un menos así que podemos
poner menos y para que se obtenga este
más ponemos el menos aquí x cuadrada
entre 3 muy bien entonces ya está
expresado esta función en esta forma que
necesitamos para saber cómo es sujeto su
perdón su serie geométrica entonces como
es que lo vamos a lo vamos a escribir
vamos a tener la suma la suma desde n
igual a cero hasta infinito muy bien en
nuestro caso quien es a pues en nuestro
caso la a es el numerador que es un
tercio
así que ponemos un tercio que multiplica
a nuestra proporción común que en
nuestro caso es x así que aquí no es x
simplemente será en nuestro caso va a
ser menos
- x cuadrada entre 3 muy bien y esto lo
elevamos a la n ahora aquí pasa bueno
vamos a vamos a desarrollar esto para
que veamos exactamente quién es y esto
sería un tercio menos aquí hay que
multiplicar un tercio por en menos x
cuadrada entre 3 por eso va el menos y
entonces x cuadrada por una equis
cuadrada entre 3 por 3 que es 9 ahora si
queremos obtener el 6 el siguiente
término multiplicamos nuevamente por
menos x cuadrada entre 3 así que va más
verdad porque tenemos menos por menos es
más
x cuadrada por x cuadrada es x cuarta y
9 por 3 son 27 aunque entonces tenemos x
a la cuarta entre 27 y así podemos ir
siguiendo para determinar esta serie muy
bien entonces esta serie representa
exactamente esta función cuando nos
encontramos en el inter
lo de convergencia entonces la pregunta
es cuando convergen cuál es el intervalo
de convergencia y te invito a que hagas
una pausa y pienses en esto
muy bien entonces vamos a checarlo
nosotros necesitamos necesitamos que el
valor absoluto de la proporción común
sea menor que 1 en nuestro caso esté
menos x cuadrada entre 3 es nuestra
proporción común así que necesitamos que
el valor absoluto de menos x cuadrada
sobre 3 sea menor que 1 muy bien pero
fijémonos que en realidad el valor
absoluto de este número negativo pues en
realidad es lo mismo que cuando tenemos
signo más entonces esto es el valor
absoluto de x cuadrada entre 3 y esto
debe ser menor que 1 finalmente pues
bueno finalmente todavía faltan varios
pasos notemos que x cuadrado entre 3 es
no negativo verdad x cuadrada siempre va
a ser mayor o igual que 0 y si dividimos
entre 3 sigue siendo mayor o igual que 0
así que el valor absoluto es exactamente
x cuadrada entre 3 y necesitamos que sea
menor que 1
vamos a abrazar resolverlo voy a seguir
por acá voy a multiplicar de ambos lados
por 3 y nos queda x cuadrada menor que 3
muy bien y si yo quiero sacar raíz
cuadrada en realidad lo que debo poner
bueno si puedo hacerlo pero del lado
izquierdo queda valor absoluto de x
menor que la raíz cuadrada de 3 y esto
ya nos está diciendo cuál es el
intervalo porque esto me está diciendo
que x debe ser más grande que menos la
raíz de 3 y más chico que la raíz de 3
así que aquí está nuestro intervalo de
convergencia intervalo de convergencia
convergencia y con esto para estas equis
entre menos raíz de 3 y raíz de 3 esta
función en esta función de aquí o esta
serie va a ser exactamente igual es
exactamente igual a woods eso fue un
poco checo es exactamente igual a 1
entre 3 más x cuadrada así que sobre el
intervalo de convergencia la función
toma el mismo valor que la serie lo cual
yo creo que es una idea fantástica